es schließt ein bisschen an das was wir
gerade jetzt diskutiert haben und es
geht um den ethikrat speziell um die
chefin ali netbooks und die hat sich
geäußert jetzt gesagt dass gerade im
rückblick und wir habe gerade über das
thema kinder und schulen gesprochen doch
einiges in der pandemie nicht richtig
gelaufen ist in meinen worten hat so
ungefähr ausgedrückt dass man doch sagen
muss da gab es viele fehler das ist
bemerkenswert denn wir wissen dass der
ethikrat gerade im jahr 2020 aber auch
im vergangenen jahr in der pandemie eine
wahnsinnig tragende rolle hat wenn nicht
sogar eine der tragenden rollen wenn es
um empfehlungen gerade an die
bundeskanzlerin ging und ich möchte
erinnern beispielsweise an das jahr 2020
vielleicht erinnern sie sich auch noch
an die sogenannte ein kind rege oder ein
freund regel die es dann mal geben
sollte also kinder sollten sich nur noch
mit einem freund treffen dürfen mit dem
gleichen freund da hat der ethikrat
gesagt eigentlich eine ganz gute idee
haben wir auch machen dann ging es um
die frage lockerung an schulen im
vergangenen herbst da hat der ethikrat
in form von frau brooke gesagt nein das
wäre der falsche weg und jetzt plötzlich
wo wir ja den freiheitstag man mag ihn
beschreiben würden will hinter uns haben
oder erlangt haben wo wir sehen das auch
in gewisser weise das thema corona etwas
ist was uns nicht mehr ganz so stark
belastet wie noch vor einigen monaten da
kommt der ethikrat auch in form von
tricks auf die idee zu sagen also es ist
doch vieles falsch gelaufen
vergangenheit ich finde das ist eine
wende helligkeit nicht zu überbieten das
ist eine billige masche das ist quasi
haltet den dieb frau brooke will sich da
offenbar auch dann und wir sprachen
gerade über die ankommt kommission
freimachen von schuld aber so einfach
wird auch das nicht sein deswegen ich
fordere auch ganz klar wir müssen das
dringend im bundestag aufarbeiten und da
gehört auch eine kritische
auseinandersetzung des ethikrates mit
dazu
ethische fragen sind ja immer fragen von
abwägung ist es ja nie etwas komplett
richtig oder komplett falsch und die
frage ist hat der ethikrat eigentlich
ethisch gehandelt denn in dieser zeit in
der die abwägung notwendig war waren war
hat diese abwägung nicht stattgefunden
jetzt wird sie nachgeholt und das ist
für mich ein eingeständnis dass die
arbeit nicht ordentlich gemacht worden
ist dass man eben nicht diese abwägung
gemacht hat welche positiven dinge haben
einschränkungen aber auch welche
negativen wirkungen haben die un jetzt
die negativen auswirkungen im nachhinein
nachzuschieben ist tatsächlich der
versuch die verantwortung die man damals
hatte zumindest auch in der öffentlichen
debatte nach motto wir sind als ethikrat
dafür was in der politik beschlossen
wird diese verantwortung ein wenig von
sich zu weisen das ist so schwierig und
wir müssen uns wirklich überlegen ob man
einen solchen ethikrat braucht der dann
erst im nachgang feste etwas es
eigentlich alles noch hätte abzuwägen
gegeben naja ich bin ja schon fast froh
also ich bin so milde gestimmt heute ich
war ja natürlich aber ich bin ja schon
froh wenn leute wenigstens im nachhinein
einsehen dass da irgendwas problematisch
gewesen ist also ich glaube der prozess
der aufarbeitung sind zwei wirklich
schwierige jahre gewesen wir haben uns
letzten endes als ganzes demokratisches
land orientiert am chinesischen
paradigma wir haben jetzt noch mal nach
shanghai guckt der sieht jetzt mit der
distanz na das ist ja wohl keine
demokratische lösung so kann man doch
nicht mit offenen gesellschaften umgehen
haben aber fast so gemacht und leute
haben das gerechtfertigt und viele haben
das mitgemacht auch in unserem beruf
staat muss man sagen und das hat dauern
also bis das sozusagen dann systematisch
und sauber aufgearbeitet ist und man ja
auch schuld zuweisen kann das wird man
müssen aber eben auch vor allem sagen
kann was hat denn jetzt wie gewirkt ich
meine ja auch schön wenn wir vielleicht
für künftige fälle dass möglicherweise
ja nicht die letzte pandemie gewesen
sein vielleicht war das auch nicht die
gefährlichste die jemals kommen wird
also wenn wir jetzt mal was draus lernen
könnten wäre es ja ganz schön und dafür
ist im prinzip ganz wichtig finde ich
was der ethikrat jetzt in diesem in
diesem 180 grad papier dann doch auch
sagt nämlich dass wir ganz viele zahlen
gar nicht haben dass also zwei
gesundheitsminister bisher offenbar also
nie so genau wissen wollten wer auf den
intensivstationen eigentlich liegt also
sind die nun geimpft oder nicht gänzlich
oft geimpft worden die sich angesteckt
sind die alt oder jung die sind
natürlich überwiegend haben
migrationshintergrund und haben damit
kommunen an oder im spiel sind immer
noch mit kohle aber mit den 200 toten im
moment die die täglich gezählt werden
die sterben ja nicht an dem tag die
wende noch an dem tag jeweils gezählt
wird ja immer noch politik gemacht im
sinne von das ist viel zu viel das geht
gar nicht die leute haben kurzes
gedächtnis im vergangenen jahr auf der
höhe der zweiten welle hat mir tausend
tote am tag da wird hört zu sagen dass
über die normale sterbliche einer ganz
anderen stil dance immer noch immer wenn
sie denn schauen würde eine um mehr als
das zehnfache niedrigere inzidenz
absolut also insofern ich bin wenigstens
froh dass die den schritt gehen nicht
darauf zu beharren vor sein sagen warum
ich habe mich ja impfen lassen und war
bin auch den hofstaat und das alles das
heißt ich habe ja gar nicht diese
gesellschaftliche aus als ich wurde ja
nicht rausgeschmissen aus der
gesellschaft weil ich war ja die gute
geimpfte aber es gab wirklich menschen
wurde rausgeschmissen und ich war bei
einer bei einer lesung vor zehn tagen
und das beispiel wird jetzt jede mir an
tisch erstmal merkwürdig vorkommen kam
es mir auch erst dann sah sie ihn
zukommt wie furchtbar und da hat mir
eine dame erzählt die hat sich mir
vorgestellt dass sie auch gerne für nach
abschalten und dass sie sich nicht
impfen lassen und wollte mir von ihren
erfahrungen im winter erzählen und dann
ist er sie konnte damit wohl gut umgehen
und dann stand sie irgendwann mal vom
geschäft was leer war und wollte sich
ohrringe kaufen deswegen ich sage alle
empfinden das als oberflächliches
beispiel und dann durften sie sich diese
ohrring ja nicht kaufen weil sie das
geschäft nicht betreten durfte was leer
war auch nicht mit maske und dann ist
sie bitterlich in tränen ausgebrochen
und erst habe ich gedacht na gut
ohrringen zu kaufen da gibt es auch
schlimmeres aber dann ein sich im zug
saß habe ich gedacht wie wahnsinnig dass
wir menschen die steuern zahlen die für
unser land arbeiten die mitglieder der
gesellschaft sind nicht erlauben in
einen leeren laden reinzugehen und
ohrringen zu kaufen und ehrlich gesagt
ich hab das beispiel ist auch extra
erzählt um zu zeigen ich nehme das ernst
und diese ohrringe geschichte nämlich
auch ernst und deswegen möchte ich dass
diese frau sich nicht nur korrigiert ich
weiß nicht was sie machen sollen bei
diesem etikett aber auf jeden fall mehr
als das ich bin irgendwie voreingenommen
weil ich möchte ganz kurz mal sagen weil
du hast so groß den hammer rausgeholt
ich finde alena wirkt einfach nach hamm
ab ohne frau und deswegen bin ich so ein
bisschen power angenommen so manchmal
ist man da so ein bisschen so ich finde
wenn sie in pressekonferenz saß als sehr
klar argumentiert sie hat sehr klar dass
da gelingt und ich tendiere auch mehr
dazu zu sagen jetzt geht man in der
korrektur hoffentlich lernen wir daraus
hoffentlich nehmen wir uns ich meine man
hört natürlich auch immer und das ist
natürlich auch ein satz den können wir
alle schon gar nicht mehr hören in
dieser pandemie jemand musste zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch nicht was man jetzt weiß
so das ist ja immer das argument damit
könnte man wieder alles aushebeln wir
wussten damals noch nicht was ist
deswegen haben wir so entschieden und
ich glaube dass wir davon ist man
langsam so ein bisschen weg kommt und
ich hoffe dass das dafür auch ein anstoß
ist dass man nicht nur sagt wir hatten
damals nicht die informationen sondern
dass man sagt gut werden das damals so
entschieden es könnte alles anders
kommen aber das sind die statute das
sind die dinge die bei hoch halten die
uns wichtig sind an denen wir uns in der
zukunft entlanghangeln wollen und wenn
wir alle einsehen würden und das führt
auch zu unserer vorhergegangenen
diskussion zurück dass kinderrechte
einfach so brutal missachtet wurden dass
wir einmal einsehen dass kinder noch
immer glaube ich glaube wir haben
erstaunlich wenig daraus gelernt noch
immer nicht die bedeutung in unserer
gesellschaft bekommen die sie verdienen
die sie brauchen die wir brauchen auch
um unsere gesellschaft dementsprechend
zu verändern dann muss ich sagen dann
ist es eine bankrotterklärung nicht nur
für den ethikrat sondern für uns alle
und ich hoffe einfach vielleicht will
ich auch milde gestimmt heute oder alena
büchs voreingenommen war wunderschön
aber ich hoffe dass daraus das
resultiert dass wir dahin kommen und
deswegen bin ich für jedes fehler
eingeständnissen wo kommen wir hin wenn
man fehler eingestanden und einen ärgern
wieder und darüber dass man das
eingesteht am ende erkennt keiner mehr
ein fehler ein und wir kommen überhaupt
nicht mehr übertrieb für das tolle ist
ja an uns menschen glaube ich auch dass
wir jemanden sympathisch finden können
wir eigentlich hier nicht der gleichen
meinung sein ob man dafür trotzdem ganz
zivilisiert auch milde gestimmt ich aus
fragen also aber eine pause so tolle
frau oder mann sagte hammermann oder man
sagt ja und trotzdem nicht einer meinung
ist ja super dass ereignet glaube ich
den menschen
ja wir besonders auf wie sonnen sie
gesprochen trotzdem musste sie jetzt sie
für eine seltenheit manchmal martin
korrigieren und hat offenbar selbst
festgestellt gewisse dinge die sie
gesagt hat war nicht richtig meine große
sorge ist eigentlich wir hatten klima
corona jetzt haben den krieg
dass wir über den krieg und das was
jetzt passiert
schon wieder auch so atemlos sind dass
wir das was war nämlich kona und die
lehren daraus und die folgen und das das
ganze missmanagement das ist ja auch
gegeben hat gar nicht richtig
aufarbeiten können
dass liegen bleibt das ist wie bei der
cdu die ja immer sagt jan machen
wahlkampf aufbereitungen hat aber nicht
stattgefunden und angela merkel
und die große befürchtung habe ich
eigentlich es gibt ja noch nicht dass
wir gar nicht dazu kommen können weil
wir jetzt schon wieder so auf krieg
geputzt und alles was da kommt da ja
auch feststellen müssen wie viele
nachlässigkeiten den letzten jahrzehnten
gegeben hat und irgendwann kommt die sap
anime und gestehen da mehr oder weniger
beim thema flüchtlinge ja auch nicht
viel anders aus 215 wenn man mal guckt
in technisch gerade flüchtlinge
registriert oder eben nicht registriert
wenn wir das oft wieder noch mit zettel
und stift geht dann muss man ist meine
befürchtung wir gehen unvorbereitet in
das nächste drama was ich da ankündigt
möglicherweise ja sicher
wo ich teile meine frage des das
besondere ist ja heute hier sitzen ja
außer mir drei journalisten
und es gibt ja noch ein anderes thema
was die bevölkerung sehr bewegt und zwar
nicht nur das versagen des ethikrates
sondern auch das versagen des deutschen
journalismus ich würde das jetzt nicht
als versagen beschreiben aber es wurde
jetzt auch festgestellt dass
in der pandemie die berichterstattung zu
einseitig war und auch da werden wir
sachen aufarbeiten müssen was den
journalismus betrifft die frage ist und
das ist meine frage an die runde die
frage ist für mich ganz klar wie können
wir denn in der zukunft verhindern dass
meinungen im diskurs gecancelt werden
weil hast du gesagt hast patricia wir
wussten ja nichts immerhin sagt es war
vorher ich kann mich an einige menschen
erinnern und darunter gab es auch
biologen und alles andere die schon vor
anderthalb jahren probiert haben zu
kämpfen dass es wäre anders vorgehen und
ich kann am schwierigsten das meinungen
so eigentlich ausgeschlossen wurden oder
abweichende meinungen werden mundtot
gemacht hat ja auch schon gast gesagt
wie wir da vielleicht vorgehen können in
zukunft das die meinungspluralität
wieder größer ist auch im journalismus
also ich glaube wir müssen zu einer ganz
anderen art von institutionalisierter
also in den einzelnen medien verankerter
medienkritik kommen es ist ja ein
bisschen schwierig ich glaube das ist ja
nun kein geheimnis dass wir hier glaube
ich alle in der runde springer
journalisten sind und ich glaube beide
häuser welt und bild haben sich nicht so
wahnsinnig viel vorzuwerfen ist eine von
dass männer meinungen gar nicht
vorgekommen und es ist auch nicht zu
bestreiten dass bei uns häufig kritik an
den öffentlich rechtlichen medien
vorkommt ich finde häufig mit guten
argumenten aber insofern gibt es
natürlich eine frontstellung und und
öffentlich-rechtliche journalisten ich
sage deutlich auf einem podium die
fühlen sich dann auch sehr leicht
angegriffen sind dann auch sauer also da
gibt es sozusagen auch eine alle häuser
konkurrenz oder wie man das nennen soll
das muss alles weg das ist dass das
bringt uns überhaupt nicht weiter
sondern ich glaube wir müssen versuchen
wieder eine kultur zu etablieren wo man
sich den einzelnen beitrag und den
einzelnen text vornimmt und sagt so da
ist aber folgende frage gar nicht
gestellt da ist sozusagen da kommt die
gegenseite ja gar nicht zu wort und da
sind sozusagen möglicherweise auch
falsche behauptungen drin und wir haben
das bei diesem konzept der false bay
sands das wurde dann bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen irgendwann
eingeführt also am anfang haben sie ja
manchmal noch versucht also mehrere
meinungen zu bringen auch wenn immer
klar war dass das team vor sich da
ziemlich am ruder war irgendwann hörte
dass dann auch auf dann hatte man sehr
gleichförmige sendung wo alle der
meinung waren es ganz gefährlich nicht
aber wenn ich das jetzt hier so sagen
kann das schon wieder wie polemik wirken
von jemand von der welt und ich glaube
wir müssen einfach an journalisten
werden natürlich auch nicht gerne
kritisiert ist keiner von uns war das
und und sind manchmal empfindlicher also
als als sie sein sollten wenn man denkt
wie sehr sie andere leute kritisieren
aber
wenn wir das etwas professioneller
wieder hinbekommen würden dass man
wirklich sich die beiträge auch mal
anguckt und sagt also nichts gegen den
kollegen sehen die kolleginnen aber dass
da habt ihr einfach was auf gelassen
dass das ist so kein rundes bild das
stimmt so nicht oder das ist eine
bösartige zugespitzt und wenn wir uns
daran wieder ein bisschen mehr gewöhnen
würden glaube ich aber das wird auch ein
prozess an der paar jahre dauert glaube
ich dass man dass man versucht also
gegenseitige medienkritik ohne ohne
diese häuser konkurrenz fan ist das
haben sie den eindruck uns ist es ein
bisschen auch abhanden gekommen und ich
frage mich woran das liegt also woran
liegt es dass wir uns auch alle selbst
in die pflicht nehmen müssen zu sagen
lasst uns diesen beitrag noch einmal
anschauen lasst uns diesen text noch
einmal anschauen also
wir alle sind vielleicht ausgewachsen in
einem journalismus weil wir gesagt haben
es ist doch klar dass all diese fragen
beantwortet werden müssen es ist klar
dass wir das prüfen es ist klar dass wir
die gegenseite abholen und uns das
anhören damit dieser artikel dieser
beitrag rund ist ich stelle mir oft
selbst die frage wann und ich habe ich
bei ihren eindruck und auch den
vorschlag dass wir da wieder hinkommen
müssen aber wann oder auch vor allem
warum droht das manchmal hinten
runterzufallen
also es ist eine komplizierte erklärung
ich bin mir auch nicht sicher ob sie
richtig ist denn uns wird man ja immer
noch ein bisschen vorwerfen also
springer am weitesten sinne die rechte
oder konservative medien zu sein das ist
das was man hört also ich hoffe ich
beleidige da niemanden aber das ist das
was man im bekanntenkreis gesagt bekommt
während ich also sozusagen aus der
innenperspektive das als relativ
pluralistisch wahrnehmen also bei der
welt haben wir unendliche diskussionen
darüber was jetzt der richtige standort
ist und ich finde auch alle diese
diskussionen im blatt wieder und in der
zeitung sozusagen die ist saumäßig
natürlich eine etwas andere zeitung aber
da kommt es mir auch so vor
aber lassen sich das mal dahin gestellt
als kinder sogar sein dass wir noch so
eine art weltanschauliche identität
haben aber ich glaube insgesamt ist die
den journalismus sehr abhanden gekommen
also es sollte kein links und rechts im
journalismus mehr geben parteilich war
auf einmal laut und man wurde
überparteilich mann wurde zum
schiedsrichter also würde sagen sie vor
20 jahren hat das allerdings
schiedsrichter weiß ich gar nicht habe
manchmal fast den eindruck gehabt auch
zum sprachrohr also zum zweiten oder
dritten regierungssprecher unter das war
ja eigentlich das was am ende in der
pandemie ein zunehmendes problem war bei
dem ein oder anderen unserer geschätzten
kollegen zu sagen ja wenn es die
bundeskanzlerin doch gesagt hat da muss
das doch so sein und wenn das der
virologe xy so gesagt dann muss das doch
so hans druckt iva schon und dann
verstärkte man das eigentlich noch und
hat die arbeit von steffen seibert
gemacht das ist glaube ich ein
kernproblem dass wir erlebt haben und
das hat sich irgendwie extrem zugespitzt
über die vergangenen anderthalb bis zwei
jahre und da stand quasi dann der
regierungssprecher eines mediums gegen
den journalisten eines anderen mediums
und hat sich natürlich verteidigt ist ja
auch die aufgabe eines
regierungssprechers er ist aber oder sie
eben kein regierungssprecher gewesen
sondern eigentlich ein journalist und da
glaube ich hat man den clash dann am
besten ja oder am stärksten gemerkt
groner war ja auch nicht das dankbarste
thema wahrscheinlich für viele kollegen
wenn ich das mal ist außenstehender
sagen darf weil er ist ein sehr zahlen
getriebenes thema war bei der welt
wurden ja sogar ein kollege aus der
wirtschaftsredaktion für die ganzen
corona zahlen abgestellte und hat die
fleißig täglich bei twitter eingestellt
hat denn so interessiert war einer der
wenigen glaube ich der diese zahlen
wirklich begriffen hat ich habe das
selbst bemerkt dass viele zahlen völlig
falsch gedeutet wurden selbst von
menschen die naturwissenschaften
studiert haben um dort in diesen zeilen
wust von grone herauszugreifen was ist
wirklich bedeutend was hat wirklich
einen einfluss was hat kein anschluss
hätte glaube ich mathematik kenntnisse
erfordert die nicht so super verbreitet
waren im journalismus das war so ein
bisschen ungünstiges thema für viele das
kann aber eigentlich auch nur ein
anderer aufrufe aldi die vielleicht
junge zuschauer die darüber auch für
viele junge zuschauer die vielleicht
journalisten werden wollen ich glaube es
lohnt sich in unseren berufszweig jetzt
vielleicht auch noch mehr auf eine
spezialisierung zu setzen also ich
glaube dass wir alle ich bin groß
geworden als journalist unter hieß es du
musst überall bescheid wissen muss sich
in jedem thema auskennen das ist
sicherlich nicht verkehrt im
journalismus ich glaube aber dass wir
zunehmend auch menschen brauchen die
sich ganz spezifisch dann in einer sache
besonders gut auskennen die wachsende
entweder rein das bringt auch eine
pandemie mit sich dass man plötzlich der
zahlen verstehe ist obwohl man aus der
wirtschaft kommt oder so aber ich glaube
dass das auch tun
ja gibt gesundheit sonst wäre das
natürlich nicht von zahlen der kollegin
es schaut eher unwahrscheinlich naja
aber dass man sich plötzlich im
gesundheits feld derjenige der sich
total auskennt und ich glaube dass das
etwas ist worauf man auch zunehmend
setzen kann wenn man leute einstellen
oder wenn wir junge journalisten sehen
dass man sagt wir brauchen eigentlich
wirklich fach menschen auch mehr